in muscle bay
south africa allison towner and enrico
janari
investigate if speed is what makes a
great white's jaws so deadly
other investigators have seen how a bull
sharks bite works
now getting a bite impression might help
them solve the mystery of how a great
white
combines bite force with thrust
the shark just came out of the water
vertical open mouth almost like saying
look at me out majestic animal i am
this is definitely the biggest shot that
we've had so far guys
he gave a big bite and he's still
playing around with
for a good two minutes so we should
have got some very nice bite in print
they've got their results and they're
revealing
wow wow didn't just bite it
launched out the water within its mouth
we couldn't have asked for better teeth
impressions look at this
this is gold
the deepest bite impressions are most
likely from the initial strike
we've got huge amounts of teeth marks
there these being the top teeth of the
shark's jaw
and then on the reverse side here we can
see the lower jaw
perfectly this shark has all of her
teeth in place
we can only move our bottom jaws for
eating
a great white can move both top and
bottom
but for a shark capable of decapitating
a seal in one bite
the damage to the decoy is surprisingly
minimal
maybe they don't have as much high back
forces other species could be that the
speed alone and the impact of the force
of the hit
is more powerful than the actual bike
force um so there's lots of complexity
to tease apart
white sharks combine bite force and
thrust to attack their prey
their teeth are long sometimes close to
seven inches
with that many daggers this shark may
not need as much bite force as a bull
shark
while the bull sharks teeth act like a
buzz saw
a white sharks function like a
guillotine
great white sharks have 24 teeth on the
top and 26 on the bottom
you can liken it to a whole series of
steak knives in a fish's mouth
the top tees are the cutters they are
highly serrated
and they are basically the teeth that
saw into the flesh of their prey
the bottom teeth are very different
they're much more narrow but equally as
serrated
so as the bottom teeth pin and hold the
prey the top teeth cut
through the flesh and those mechanics
together make the bite so powerful
and so effective
[Music]
you